Transcription: Almudena Torrecilla
Relecteur: Anne-Sophie Matichard
Wow, vous êtes super impressionnants !
Peut-être que je vais me mettre à rougir,
à avoir la voix qui tremble,
peut-être même avoir des trous de mémoire.
Mais c’est normal.
Alors, vous allez peut-être
trouver ça un petit peu étrange
pour un ancien sapeur-pompier de Paris,
pour un ancien sportif de haut niveau,
thérapeute depuis presque dix ans
et qui a accompagné
des dizaines de personnes
à gérer leurs peurs et leurs angoisses
avec plein d’outils comme l’hypnose,
le modèle de Palo Alto,
la PNL et bien d’autres choses.
Alors, comment fait-on pour apprendre
à gérer ses angoisses ?
Comment fait-on pour avoir le sentiment
d’avoir le contrôle de nous-même ?
Pour avoir confiance en soi ?
Malheureusement, la réalité,
quand on est anxieux, est bien différente.
Ce sont toujours les mêmes angoisses
qui reviennent encore et encore.
On n'arrête pas de ressasser, de ruminer.
On se pose toujours les mêmes questions.
On a beau essayé de les faire taire,
de penser à autre chose,
et pourtant, elles reviennent sans cesse,
comme une obsession.
Est-ce qu’il y a parmi vous
des gens qui ont déjà ressenti cet état ?
Peut-être à main levée.
Ok. Alors l’idée aujourd’hui,
c’est que vous puissiez repartir
en comprenant mieux
le fonctionnement de la peur,
mais surtout en ayant trois clés
pour vous aider à la vaincre.
Dans mon cabinet,
pour accompagner mes clients
à gérer leurs peurs et leurs angoisses,
j’utilise notamment
l’approche de Palo Alto.
Et avant ça, on va déjà essayer
de comprendre :
qu’est-ce que c’est que la peur ?
Alors déjà, la peur,
si on prend la définition du Larousse,
c’est un sentiment d’angoisse éprouvé
à la présence ou à la pensée
d’un danger réel ou supposé.
Ok, très bien, mais concrètement,
qu’est-ce qui se passe
dans notre cerveau ?
En fait, lorsque l’un de nos sens
détecte quelque chose de suspect,
il envoie un signal à l’amygdale.
Elle, par des projections neuronales,
va envoyer un signal sur le tronc cérébral
qui va activer différents noyaux,
qui vont activer toutes
les réactions physiologiques.
C’est pour cette raison que,
sous l’influence
du système nerveux parasympathique,
notre respiration s’arrête,
notre rythme cardiaque ralentit
et nous restons tétanisés
devant le danger potentiel.
Alors, simplement, à ce moment-là,
le cortex intervient.
Il analyse la situation et nous amène
soit à l’affronter, soit à fuir.
Ok.
Donc, tout simplement,
la peur c’est un signal
que nous envoie notre cerveau
pour nous dire : « Attention, danger ! »
Le but premier n’est pas de la faire
disparaître complètement,
mais au contraire, d’en faire un moteur
ou une protection.
Comme je le disais,
la peur, c’est comme ça que je travaille
dans mon cabinet,
j’utilise l’approche de Palo Alto.
Donc, l’approche de Palo Alto,
qu’est-ce que c’est ?
L’approche de Palo Alto,
c’est sur elle que se construit
l’approche systémique et stratégique.
C’est une approche qui est non-normative
et non-pathologisante.
Elle ne cherche pas les solutions
dans les causes liées au passé,
mais se concentre sur ce
qui se passe ici et maintenant.
Le Mental Research Institute
émet l’idée selon laquelle
un problème n’existe pas en soi,
mais que la façon dont
nous réagissons aux problèmes de la vie
peuvent amener celui-ci
à devenir une réalité.
Paul Watzlawick, l’un des pères fondateurs
de l’école de Palo Alto,
disait cette formule célèbre
et paradoxale :
« Le problème c’est la solution. »
Alors,
Simplement avant ça -
on va prendre un exemple
pour mieux expliquer,
et cet exemple est le mien.
Comment gérer ma peur de parler en public
pendant cette conférence ?
La première chose à faire
est donc d’analyser
mes tentatives de solutions
dysfonctionnelles pour gérer mes peurs.
Alors, lorsqu’on m’a pris
pour cette conférence TEDx,
la première chose était avoir ressenti
la joie, l’excitation.
Et puis, très vite, j'ai commencé
à avoir mes premières craintes.
Qu’est ce que tu vas raconter ?
Il faut faire quelque chose d'intéressant.
Il faut que ça plaise aux autres.
Et très vite, ces craintes ont commencé
à se transformer en angoisse.
Alors j’ai commencé à essayer
de me rassurer, me détendre :
« T’inquiète pas, tu vas faire
un truc super, t’en es capable,
t’as déjà fait plein de conférences.
Tu vas peut-être même avoir
une standing ovation à la fin. »
Mais vous l’avez compris,
ça n’a pas vraiment fonctionné
et mes peurs ont continué de grandir.
La peur n’est pas très appréciée
des êtres humains,
qui, la plupart du temps, la considèrent
comme une sensation qu’il faut craindre
ou une faiblesse à éviter.
C’est pour ça que le premier réflexe,
quand on a une peur, une angoisse,
c’est d’avoir tendance à vouloir
essayer de la faire taire, la retenir,
la garder à l’intérieur de soi.
Et pourtant, inexorablement,
celle-ci ne fait que s’exacerber.
La peur,
si on l’encourage au lieu de la fuir
ou de la réprimer,
va se saturer par ses propres excès.
Et assez paradoxalement, le fait de faire
cet exercice m'a rendu plus serein.
Ça m'a amené à affronter ma peur.
Ça m'a rendu plus fort.
Alors, c'était très bien, j'avais pu gérer
mes peurs avant la conférence.
Mais maintenant, comment gérer ma peur
pendant la conférence?
Comme je vous l’ai dit,
ma peur était d’avoir
des réactions physiologiques :
la voix qui tremble, des trous de mémoire,
peut-être même de rougir.
Et si on suit le modèle de Palo Alto,
l’idée c’est d’essayer de ne pas
contrôler ses réactions physiologiques.
Souvenez-vous des premières phrases
de cette conférence.
« Wow, vous êtes super impressionnants !
Peut-être que je vais me mettre
à trembler,  à rougir,
même avoir des trous de mémoire. »
Je vous ai déclaré mon secret :
c’est ma deuxième clé.
C’est-à-dire que j’ai annoncé
ce qui me faisait peur.
Et le fait d’annoncer ce qui fait peur
permet de s’en libérer,
permet d’arrêter d’essayer de le contrôler
et nous amène à nous apaiser
et à nous en libérer.
Alors, je vous invite simplement
à déclarer votre petit secret honteux.
Montrez jour après jour
une petite faiblesse
qui vous emprisonne dans la peur.
Cela va vous permettre de vous en libérer
et de vous sentir
plus fort et plus serein.
Enfin, je termine avec une troisième clé,
qui n’est pas vraiment une clé,
mais qui est plutôt une erreur
que font la plupart des gens
qui sont stressés ou anxieux.
C’est la tentative d’éviter
ou de fuir ce qui fait peur
ou la demande d’aide à un ami.
Lorsqu’on fait ça, on rentre
dans une stratégie d’évitement.
Alors forcément, à court terme,
ça nous amène une sensation de bien-être.
On se sent apaisé.
Puis, à court et moyen terme, forcément,
on va ressentir de l’insatisfaction
et puis du regret.
Et puis, à long terme,
ça va générer encore plus d’anxiété.
Ça va amplifier l’évitement et générer
encore plus d’insatisfaction.
La stratégie serait alors
la stratégie d’exposition aux risques.
C’est-à-dire, sur du court terme,
qu’est ce que ça va amener ?
Forcément une certaine appréhension,
un certain inconfort,
le fait de pouvoir se confronter
à sa peur.
À court et moyen terme, ça va forcément
amener de la satisfaction,
une bonne estime de soi.
Et puis, sur du long terme, ça va amener
la confiance en soi, la sérénité
et ça permet de nous sentir plus serein
grâce à l’apprentissage.
Alors, je vous invite à observer
dans votre quotidien,
toutes les fois où, à cause d’une peur,
vous ne faites pas, vous ne dites pas,
ou vous faites ou dites certaines choses
de peur de ce qui pourrait se passer,
de peur des conséquences.
Si c’est justifié, ok.
Mais si ça ne l’est pas,
il faut être conscient
qu’à chaque fois que vous faites ça,
vous êtes juste en train de vous renfermer
dans votre cercle vicieux,
d’alimenter votre peur.
Alors, simplement aujourd’hui,
j’aimerais vous dire un grand merci,
parce que ce soir,
je viens d’affronter mes peurs.
Je n’avait jamais parlé
devant tant de personnes.
Du coup, je me sens beaucoup plus serein,
j’ai beaucoup plus confiance en moi.
J’aimerais juste vous rappeler une chose.
La seule et unique façon pour
se débarrasser d’une peur,
c’est de l’affronter.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)